GRACE TEO: I will say
that one of the things
that I used be pretty insecure
about as an educator-- to put
this in context,
I just graduated
with my Ph.D. over the summer.
And after spending five years
working on one niche problem,
you're like, all
right, well I don't
have a lot of usable
skills, I just
have a lot of knowledge
about this one tiny problem.
What can I possibly teach?
And so I used to think
about that a lot.
But something this
class showed me
was that actually just the
ability to be entrepreneurial,
the ability to be adaptable,
the ability to be a facilitator,
a communicator, mediator
between people-- which I think
were all huge parts
of this class--
was the most important thing
in being an educator here.
So it wasn't so much about
knowledge of subject material,
or knowledge of a specific
skill, but just the ability
to facilitate learning, which
a lot of times just comes
down to knowing how to ask
the right questions of what
is needed at this moment to help
my student learn and succeed,
and being able to
answer their questions.
So I didn't need to
know the knowledge.
I didn't need to
have the skills.
But I just needed to
know where to find
that knowledge and skills
and be able to bring
my student to that place.
WILLIAM LI: Yeah, wow.
So I think this is a
challenging question to answer,
what I learned in terms of
teaching or being an educator.
One thing I'd say-- so I'm
currently a Ph.D. Student.
And so this semester, as
a graduate instructor.
It was a little bit
unexpected certainly,
to be involved in teaching
the course this semester.
And to try to carry on and
extend the work that Seth
Teller had done in this
class was to me, personally
a very monumental undertaking.
Seth was my master's
thesis adviser,
and I worked on assistive
technology with him
and saw him teach the
class the first time,
and gone to some of the classes
and helped out a little bit
in the last two years
or three years as well.
So to suddenly be
a co-instructor
of the class with Grace
was a sudden, almost kind
of jarring experience.
A baptism of fire, perhaps.
So maybe there's
three things to say.
One is, it was
immensely challenging.
It is different from doing
research, which is mostly what
I'm doing as a Ph.D. student.
Even working on projects
with different people,
you sort of have this
one level removed,
where suddenly-- as
Grace was talking
about-- working with students,
and trying to encourage them
in certain directions.
And there's certainly
some uncertainty
associated with that.
Or whether they will take
your advice, I guess,
or whether you should nudge
them further in this direction.
Or sometimes they surprise you.
Very often, frankly,
they surprise you.
Very pleasantly,
in terms of what
they're able to accomplish
over the semester.
So how to inspire
or mentor students
is really something that I
learned over the semester.
I think a part of this is
that it was pretty emotional.
Maybe that's the right word.
In terms of the
history of this class,
the very personal nature of it.
I think we got to know
our 35 students very
well over the semester,
and certainly the clients
as well, the 11 clients
that we worked with.
And so you really
experience the ups and downs
with the students over the
course of the projects.
And that's
challenging sometimes,
or interesting to experience.
I think the third
thing I'd say is
that it was, in the end, very
rewarding, to see the results,
and see students excited
about what they had done.
To be able to work with a
really great team of people all
passionate about the course.
So co-instructors,
and our teaching
and lab assistants who had taken
the class before and really
wanted to make this a positive
experience for students.
I think in a lot of senses,
this is pretty unprecedented.
I don't know if I
will ever do anything
like this again for
a fairly long time,
I guess in terms of
the meaningfulness
and the challenge and
the personal side of it.
I might be waxing poetic.
But I think it was really
exciting to be able to put
something like this together.
And for that matter, I
think it's one reason
to try to share our
full experience really.
The things that worked, and
things that maybe didn't work
as well on something like OCW.
Warts and all, I suppose,
in terms of what we tried,
and what was successful,
and what guidelines we
might have to other educators.
So I think really the
focus of our class,
or if we've delivered a
good class this semester
and provided a good learning
experience for our students,
and our students have learned
and taken away something
from Principles and Practice
of Assistive Technology
this semester, then I think
that's what we set out to do.
If we can inspire educators
and students elsewhere,
who might be interested
in assistive technology,
or working in this space, if we
can kind of let 1,000 flowers
bloom when it comes to
assistive technology or the work
that we're doing,
then maybe we've
done our job this semester.